mimmo bring each other happiness I wanna
know
the thirst for the cheese is real I
won't take a shower and cheese I'm from
Wisconsin I live for this Twinkies are
like cockroaches
the only things left after a nuclear
holocaust ooh look at that
oh I would like to reiterate that this
is the amazing cheese though uh-huh
when I was out in tastin on a ski trip
fine too
I never have these burgers like ever in
my real life I guess none of it I do
this is what the Swiss made this for a
moment we're so good it's like a croque
monsieur but with like a McDonald's
burger can I have yours after if you're
not gonna do
Oh God yes I'm gonna put it in the
middle he's going for it
mm-hmm it's wizard I don't know what's
wrong with me I really like this I'm
doing nothing
oh good another one fondue fun
definitely do
what's next
hey pickles have you hate pickles maybe
you'll like them with he's on it alright
that's a fair point
oh my god it just hits like part of a
family Oh No
tastes like fondue mm-hmm
do it all day fondue this go on do this
Oh sushi I'm going to vomit
I haven't been able to follow it yeah I
can't smell it on bond Italy don't now
I'm like sad yeah yes yes to all the
things we just did except for the things
that you said no - I don't even care
about that I got the cheese sweats
yeah or should we say it was fun do